a9
Now, let's all the guests use the
carender.
I can't
say enough about him.
I'm spending the
day in Spain jtest indie
sidemweb
And how my life has changed Um bangs
Ah yes,
That woman Glory As for that girl,
it's all of you.
but I have the number 4
and sleep in a curve
re 2asa ni green rgba
swear starter in story
Continue  Together with the director, the screenplay for this work
is especially painful.
Yes, that's all for the secure
march Yes, that's
all.
search carreras too
re re 4 me so far People
Do you think Abu's work is beautiful
?
I don't think it's magic
magic.There's something called Ise Force at the very end
.  Right after the release of The Last Jedi,
I feel really sad
. Please, Bonnie
Dark
Oak
.
's a woman on my side. Yes, thank you.
Oh yeah.
say
8At the beginning, Lucas said, "This is
the heart and soul of the Wars series.
Driver Won Cream Scene Fair.
and in that work this time, the nbts pad 4 sccaren gw of the circuit series
is what shines, actually, it's a letter
Agent Chris has successfully published the story.
First
of all, the young leader who leads the resistance. First of all,
that press from Singapore
. Prilive arjan asante By using the footage.
I thought there was something interesting, wasn't there
?
How
do you feel?
I didn't know about the process, so
with a really strong force that is about the same as the character in the
movie
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe Po 4 voodoo male
and legend
Kleer stone nob 19
nbu
that lives in that house Awakened Regis Sansu The last hope elixir
Continuing on, outstanding ability to take action in a
family of three generations.  It's been a long time since I've been in the middle of a long time, and I'm going to have a
George Lucas's outstanding talent is 77
Boyle, and his nails are careful
to ask you more about
this
enderman.  Everyone is probably tired
Pot 4 me to do
Boyega?  I'm
having a wonderful time in a Japanese style
.
Arc Satipus without a way in hot water It's
dangerous to
amazing How many times have I had sex with a book
There is a moment when I think about how it ends
Now, let's talk a little more individually from here  He
likes do and video Chris Pepler bad
So let's continue Mr. Cristerio How about creating support in a situation like
dadad  So by all means, the question is, as the first
, I love that
Star Wars.
Line Vickers Green Summary I
'm sorry that I've been appearing in this saga for a long
time, but I'm wearing a shirt in the middle and it
matches the web name in Star Wars, but I
can't do it without Princess Layer  This is
Fefefefefefefefefefefea A logic tape have a swing
Wars Nome U.S. Army
c6a I found them among the people
Thank you very much for that fatherly thank you Thank you so much
.
I'm honored to be able
to name it. Read
andere surface 5 re
Camille meeting view 25
pft Scene This
will be the last scene
.  Also Knights of Ren
render
Chex xandros Bertie Gin That
's the best thing I can say is air Of course that j When
I think of it as Wars, I still think about it
.
Well then, let's
J. Sou
Star The
editor is London. That movie.
but
I also think that I want this kind of Lucas to be mele j in the future.
Action
world ain
Then I'm sorry to continue, please raise your hands
re a 4 a jenku sr
Many people are connected by that
and the underlying theme
Is that
the basic
theme?  Thank you
Mr. Kathleen Kennedy
,
what do you think?
Pre-production and post-production now
Thanks to them, very important things are important
-10 part 4 ad 1000 to
erone burago in jelly
game with formerly dual
di to
How do you feel about rper viewing
?  From here on, we would like
to ask you some questions.
8jjandKathryn
Beading Staff Game Game I chose
to do post-production as a pet shoot
.
And today, a star
has appeared, and I had to make a
and I had to make it
audience also last this
or friendship or ha brain mustard in the cemetery
den den
, I have a problem with the answer I
also Ajiko, a member of the staff who mailed
me to that hostel.
sample station 4 c point
bmi it depends on the
person huh?  Actually,
there were so many different theories about bread, and I was
doing things like gnu, but I don't know if there was one.
Will there be opportunities to interact with people from all over the world
? Thank you.
Mr. Supervised
Please wait a little longer I myself
talk to you as a family, but I would like to praise Bando City and
sure ddrender
npo Goods Thank you
for your performance.  If
you have any
thoughts, please let me
It's dark, that's why pou is the
most wonderful
thing.
I would like to use it for those
who buy it.
Of course, what comes out is the story of a family that didn't grow up well
.
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe) please raise the question
?
People in the city holding 9 shaku Rave jear on Buber It
I'd like to ask the tax director I
thought it was a concept midi glow have you
hey lots of writers  Because there are people
here, I'm the one who's here, is
n't
it?  Do you really want to take this walk
? I think I can have a party in right now,
but I don't think it's very basic
.
Kathleen Kennedy 23, Film Shamachi,
get a Zaku, but every time you come, it's a great experience
.
How is it going to be made
?  And that
ordering 6 media form
darts
dou
leather the
blogyou can introduce
me I can't think of it right now I think I was able to do that part
Daisy Ridley I
will do the
reason and why I am a human being
I think it was really I Action
Fefefefefefefefefefefefe But how did you do it there?
So how do
dog faction tandem 80% bouzouki pinbo your company name
zenny so
Japanese comics were also very sad
to
alejandra aprende to
myself from the very beginning I was forced to participate a
do  U
you do
I want to start a new trilogy It's the first time I
've played a god game It
felt strange, but that
's how I feel about our research
If I knew that this would be a good ending  The moment you
crossed it benben Big naa b 2
I think all the old works continue
rassor Stones we are
I thought it might be 4 people,
but actually we discussed
it
.  It's
I want to do it 8
When I put out these state scripts in the trailer, I think
it's vfx because it's okay to laugh in this movie, so I think it's
Lucas' conception of the hospital district, which was a from electrophoresis 7,
is the future of the script that I wrote in the past
.
fefefefefefefefefefe
, but this is quite Kurosawa
sore to do bollie house
batting stage parrot pea
can you please raise your hand?
It became that very important work that
Sari-san was for use earlier.  I
just bought it, renren are
you I think, but go with Star Wars engei
Yes, thank you everyone for coming
Aejon true
do jnsr Jeans to
sa
There was that joy too Fefefefefefefe
Thank you so much, well then today is
ah ah with a little pony priority
destination wedding
me to dopr Sub
now Otsu Gone ceo m 4
s pearl beads abu ent sumo power
I feel like I have four lives than
thank you
It's really crazy and really crazy, and my
subordinates are also playing games at Chinese
facilities, aren't they?  If you have any questions,
discoloration 42 years Pony 2 ead You're a wonderful person, so please take care
ofthispink
one.
There may be some choice
points, but
I hope everyone will refrain from doing so.
Luigi to eat
Um, well, I'll say something sad earlier Anders Oh
figure sting boys
Sports pink net some already p
session  Thank you very much for your time
hanaso danse 9 eg
.Dake En March
Write a new scene and
do4sidenbcanbe
ok Louver
Unamie  I can't even imagine what it's like to be
there, but I'm really happy to hear that you're all gathering together with a sense of feeling.
In regards to inn we all pearl daisy
salesman you are
having a great time and this work
an ending that
's appropriate for your thoughts, isn't it?
I plan to return to normal, and one of them
is that I can't move,
so I'm probably doing that part of another movie
.
I'm here
do for wii we are
so sorry Ujino now
there is a specific reason  There is a j person and I'm
Fefefefefefefefefefefefe Fefefefefefefefefefefe Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
in that really fun time here
now Please refrain from asking questions.
I can't see how cute it is, so can you always
listen to me from the
By the way, actually today is the 12th group Sazuka's
thoughts.  I have a
question for everyone, but first of all, the best of this old work is
Star Wars, which can already be called a legend.
It's too much and it's a legend Swing I'm
excited and it's very good
but that other than that is that do you
bo  is
storing the process up to that point is very difficult
please thank you roberry berry happy
i love that bunch of space tape that coaster ladies  eh
movie school Influenced by that work
it was also a good experience I
like it from such things
Perth It's a
concept, but during the shoot, I received the really best
ir Arsis Pro Shop j Boo Boo
curation,
but the first thing I said was that I'm a child
of you, but the
fabrication just happened.
I'm really excited that he's going to make the guidance,
so I'm really excited about getting it to the customers
.
we were rejected by the view of the world that they also created.
It's been 4 years, and if you include filming, it
her material is important.  I
like it, so I brought the kids along, well, it's a
big horse  It's an existence, and it's very much healed by the family
's traditional Japanese technique of
Kintsugi.
jmeterGoo,
first
of all, I'm going to talk about the screenplay stage.
I would like to ask you
for a little explanation.
Thank you.
Please refrain from talking about the book for a while
.
Well, there's just one problem, rej
nome, meeting Oscar and ag, angleberger
Please raise your hand.
Kenone France takes to
the front lines of Star Wars, but I feel a
little sad, but I
said it was just a joke to celebrate.
The third stage is the audience
, Cathay Cathy, and I
'm looking forward to sharing the three things with everyone.
I
've been doing this for a long time, but finally, everyone,
Fisher, using the actual image of her
do one by one, then let's make use of it
I think you're at home, but
anservice,sensor,chain,dase, prowl,
online,
thank you very
much.
If you say a jj, what is the relationship you had with that person
?
I'm here, but that's it
. I'm in Taylor Park
is about renewing the place where Carrie is out,
so we think it's important to
board cross the voodoo
Microway Wow c is dark.
an
1000 yen
one
more time at the end.  As a
fan who puts a lot of burden on me, I'm really
erasing to
it, but I'm finally thinking of the conclusion of one story.
WhatI've
been talking about is what's been going on all this time
is spending time with friends and that goodbye right
now it's very unrealistic.
I
have to run to understand what's going on in
the process, and I
have to run to understand
what's going on.  Takashi Murakami also
thought of this work, and it's crazy, so it's pretty good.
That's
how much I love the world-class Nose. It
's under the costume, isn't it?
I think that the relationship is beautiful
, and that line in
c3po was also loved
by the carry-on
people.
I saw it when I was in Arborea, so at that time, Omi Wan Kenobi
appeared in this work, which is Kangetsuen in the story of the house
.
Some people
think it's a bit bittersweet to think
that it's going to end.
Um, I'm really itching to do what's called the Force,
and I have a question for
Fort Worth to be Sting,
so I've prepared time for a photo shoot.
patch
voodoo fish leaders pain
was there anything like the name of
the planet from hag Takada in Tokyo at the press conference?
I was satisfied, but
I was able to create an environment with that kind of refund, so I would appreciate
your cooperation.
It's a movie
movie 3, but this is that very
healing song s day
ration here and there four people like this
for me to the
end do
haaimporttoolbarsetand
uses  for face fa
fa I am very honored to be at the stage of presenting ideas.  I will take
responsibility, so please stand
up and look forward to the questions.
I think there are
all kinds of fans
, but I think it's possible to discuss more about how to cooperate and collaborate.
Well, the
fact that I can really share with you in the
future
is a good feeling, isn't it
?  But it really made me feel very
sad.And it was so
fun that you filmed in Jordan
.
I don't want to cast
it, so it's a new reason, isn't it? This is a very sentimental
usaron
People also said on twitter that they were all connected, and that's why
I created this creature.
To hide his face and not be able to see it at all
Of course, it
's Anthony Daniel, who's
going to be open to
the public.
I would like to say thank you to a certain Japan.
Since the meeting is still in the North Sea
+4 as long as force
, I hope that many people will
come to this venue today.  Lark
: Of course, it is his performance, and it is
the experience of facing pollution that is
imminent.
Thank you.
Please understand this j 4 mese I
had the freedom to choose,
but I think I understand this, but anyway do do
doguranusfarscape
It
was more difficult than I said,
but I think it's a difficult and cultural silver prize
talented cast or jj's
coming to exchange ids and make things happen
. Thank you.
Well, at that time,
I think it's very important
to see the words that were said at that time.
I think it was like a summary of various things
Thank you very much.
I know about this Force, but when I
recover from a gel that fits very well,
how does Mr. Gru's life look like in this work?
I don't want to do it again, and
it's been released again, and it's a
great honor.
With the name of the media, the name,
Dokata, and many of the fans, I really had the
best experience recently.I
received a lot of questions.
Kass started
that aarezoi, well, now he's with us, and
even if there's actually
no one, it's a secret that he kept it a secret even with such flaws.
I'm very happy to be able to cherish the three stages of my life so far
and share it with irena, who is very close to my heart, and I'm very excited because the
media
are here.
I think it's going to lead to the ending I think 1 I'm going to keep it firmly in my heart,
but I haven't used any of them.
It's because of the idea that he's doing the results, and the
voice is also his, and it's
more than a
star work.
When it comes to the
age and the reason why it attracts which gender,
it is true that it was a difficult process for the
market.All the fans who saw the trailer were
wondering how this was done, jj Abrams
.
So I think
it's not very difficult for an actor to say that the most important thing in the market is to create the history of movies that are the most important thing in the market.
I'm aware that I
might have to say goodbye to all of you, saying that I can't
do anything good.  Windoway, the source of bonds tied together,
really, if that scene this time and
Restia Tia Johnny 4
Educe, the idea that everyone has is Kurisha,
thankyou.
And
I didn't want to use it in Lou's format
product name, Mr. Abe Gumi
, said that he first set up an octopus shop.
With from Regular Poulsen May
I ask the questions of the overseas media from here
? Usmc Ford with Ford
I think it's an honor.
What kind of experience was it to write?
I think, especially I want to include the actors here and
paste goods,
but I completely agree with everything that Oscar said.
So, this script is episode 78
, but I think that this work will continue
to inherit the spirit of everyone,
so I
faced that hurdle, but I was still really a child
.
I was very proud that I met you, and
I was able to laugh and
smile.
Actually, I would like to ask the director for the first time in several and a half years Sam is going to the four eco stages at the same time
.
Thank you.
Please tell me
what it means I'm bursting with delusions
Eh, private land support is gold and it's very easy to understand 9 light
created a work Star
I think it's a concept notion
I couldn't say it until now, and it
not wanting to use popular characters
.
There's also the danger that it might be, so do
n't hide it, would you rather take it to
this place?  I think it's just Staos, I
don't
say it, but I'm going to the park for a while.
The second eye doctor is a post
stormtrooper and an extermination
defenseman and I think that the heart is around everyone
server ah,
the friend i met is finger
douhonestoworkto be
here again jg  For
that reason,
this is the first time that everyone will be performing together in the
room.I was frustrated and it was
a magical experience.
I'd like to continue to listen to what you've learned
about me, but
what kind of meaning did you come up with with the participation of jr-like patterns?
His voice,
like
magic was created.
right? 2 It may have a meaning, but
the note still wars.
usa
b again 39 is a star
It's safe to say that it's tropical even in words thank
youthank yousomuchnowandinformation
dou  Centering on theghostJeongwonandSwing,
It took me two years before the addition,
and I
didn't know that there was a change in the production
of soy
sauce.
I'll finish that Anthony Daniel,
and well,actually, in the world ofthiswork,for
Meida,I'm enjoying myfourthlife
,sowhen I talk about the script, it'sthescript
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music  ]
[music]
[laughter]
[applause]
[music]
[laughter]
[applause]